mon meilleur souvenir c'est en tant
qu'animateur un vendredi soir où
bertrand chamerois via nous présenter
une vidéo est appelée super niche
encontre mafia enfin film complètement
lucide en christophe carrière avec une
interview du réalisateur on avait vu des
extraits c'était une femme en fait un
agent secret qui se servait de ses gros
seins pour envoyer des balles dans des
appareils photo à cette énergie d'un
gros test et on est parti mais dans un
fou rire que je n'oublierai jamais mes
moments incera mais c est quand même je
me rappelle et shy'm et j'ai dû le faire
une chorégraphie à l'érotique sur l'île
je faisais là servent à la baraque à
travers ça j'ai fait shakira avec des
plumes bon canton mais là encore je
garde un super souvenir de ça parce que
quand on se voyait en coulisses avant
d'entrer quand cyril nous appeler et que
vous voyez verdez à moitié à poil avec
des plumes à côté vous envoyer un autre
et ans regarde et on se disait me
connaît ridicule tous les trois mais
d'un autre côté quand on était dans cet
esprit de bon des deux groupes
voilà je me rappelle que quand on était
assis à la table quand l'employeur et vd
10 et les autres étaient morts de rire
bourse avec de toute façon le lendemain
ce serait nous qui avons avisé et sert
vraiment ça a été voilà c'était
l'ambiance potache de colonies de
vacances on se faisait des blagues tout
c'est vraiment génial
[Musique]
t'es pas un invité en particulier mais
j'ai eu la chance ma position atp ap
fait que c'est toujours assis aux côtés
d'invités et les femmes subiront qui
sont nus et j'ai eu la chance d'être à
côté de donana moi j'aime m'amuser
regarder toujours l'écran de contrôle
et souvent quand je voyais que la caméra
était sur la glace et j'avais tendance à
ne mettre un peu comme ça pour qu'on me
voit bien d'un côté quoi mais c'est vrai
comme une chance devant les invités
justin
[Musique]